of course not Kevin cork is traveling
with the president reports tonight from
Quebec City good evening Kevin evening
Brett even before leaving the White
House the president raised a few
eyebrows around the globe by suggesting
Russia should be here taking part in the
talks just the latest reminder of his
unconventional style and to some his
imprudence approach to global politics
and it may not be politically correct
but we have a world to run out of the g7
which used to be the g8 they through
Russia out they should let Russia come
back in because we should have Russia at
the negotiating table
it was quintessential Trump and on
rejoinder about Russia before leaving
for the g7 summit we've operated across
the globe and careened across the
partisan political divide here at home
why are we having a meeting without
Russia being in the meeting and I would
recommend and it's up to them but Russia
should be in the meeting Russia was
kicked out of the g8 because it invaded
Ukraine and annex Crimea the president
sentiment that the Russians should be a
part of the gathering here in Quebec
clearly at odds with many in his own
party and some key allies from around
the world including the UK which weighed
in with a statement that read in part
the Prime Minister has always said we
should engage with Russia but beware
we've seen malign activity from Russia
in a whole variety of ways before any
conversations can take place about
Russia rejoining it needs to change its
approach once on the ground in Quebec
the president stood with world leaders
for the traditional family photo though
the smiles seemed to belie the tension
beneath the surface just ahead of the
summit the president raged on Twitter
about unfair trade calling out America's
allies for their steep tariffs on
American goods like Canada's 270 percent
tariff on u.s. dairy while demanding
increased access and reciprocity his
counterparts fired back threatening to
go it alone if the US slammed members
with steep tariffs the United States are
naturally a great economic power but if
they continue towards a form of
isolationism
brutal hegemony of distancing themselves
from their own history and their own
values from the role they play in
international organizations that will be
bad for the United States of America but
going it alone might be difficult for
the rest of the group
considering the u.s. GDP for 2018 is
expected to top 20 trillion dollars more
than the other members combined White
House officials confirm the president is
expected to leave the summit hours
earlier than originally planned to make
way for the North Korean summit and
Singapore a visit which is stoked
concerns on Capitol Hill that the
president might try to end run Congress
to forge a deal in the same manner that
his predecessor did with the Iran
nuclear accord I would only do a deal if
I get it through Congress I wouldn't do
like Obama did you know he tried to get
it through the Iran deal he tried to get
it through Congress failed so he just
did it without earlier this evening the
president suggested that a joint
statement with Canada on tariffs was
still very likely at the conclusion of
his visit here Brett though a full
communique here at the conclusion is
still far less likely Brett
Kevin corks traveling with the president
Kevin thank you